for more on this giving tuesday in our
eye on money cbs news business analyst
jill schlesinger joins us with some tips
on how you can help plus how to make
sure your money goes to the people you
want to help jill good morning
welcome so the the donation rules have
changed in this year
of the pandemic how exactly have they
changed
there was a great provision it's tucked
into the cares act from the springtime
which actually allows more taxpayers
to do well give money but also get a tax
benefit
it used to be before the pandemic you
had to be an itemizer of deductions
in order to get a tax benefit from
giving now with this provision
any taxpayer can get up to three hundred
dollars
deduction from their taxes by giving to
a qualified charity so this is really
good news
of course many people in need we just
heard that story so more than ever
300 bucks is certainly within many
people's reach
it's usually for the tax it's for a tax
return total so if you file
jointly you'll get three hundred dollars
and be
clear that that money is needed
jill the irs is warning though that
coveted charity scams
are on the rise right now how do you
protect yourself against those
the most prevalent and pernicious of
these scams is a
text message that appears to be coming
from the irs itself it's not
obviously but what happens is that you
get a message and it says
hey anthony do you want to get that 1200
stimulus check
send us your bank information well
that's a big red flag everyone
just know the irs will never send an
unsolicited text
they will not send an unsolicited email
they will not give you
a call where they're feeling where you
feel pressure to pay something
if you are worried and you have contact
with an organization
get the employee identification number
run it through the irs.gov
search tool to make sure it's a
legitimate charity all right joel how
can you find out if your donation
actually goes to the charity you intend
uh
intend for to its cause i should say and
not somewhere else
there are a number of resources the
better business bureau has this wise
giving alliance there's chad
charity navigator charity watch give
well what you can see in these
organizations
is how much of your money goes to the
cause what goes to the overhead
good rule of thumb in general is to say
about 75
should go to the cause rather than
perhaps a big infrastructure so check it
out you can also read comments about
what other people think of those
charities
all right jill schlesinger on this
giving tuesday thanks jill